hello and welcome to the 11th weekly
episode of the Google cloud platform
podcast I'm from second boy and I'm here
with my co-host Marvin L hey Mark how
are you doing I'm good thanks for incest
how are you doing pretty good very
excite about this episode touching
something that I think is very
controversial at least the name I know a
lot of people that don't really like it
okay talking about internet of things
instead of things yeah what it really is
and why is everybody talking about it's
pretty a pretty popular topic yet to the
point that we have a developer advocate
in our own Tim that that reaction yeah
it's a lot on it so we're gonna have her
today yep but before that let's talk
about the cool thing of the week
definitely so you pointed this out to me
earlier today I thought it was pretty
interesting Udacity has a deep learning
course yeah I saw that on Twitter on the
Google cloud go about Twitter uh yeah
it's actually very interesting because I
know that there was a a bunch of courses
around about machine learning yeah some
of them created by google but this the
first deep learning course so deep
learning what does that entail well it's
not only about neural networks but it's
more about what kind of information you
can extract out of basically everything
it's it's quite interesting because it's
actually applied so they show you the
theory yep according to Udacity it's
around a three-month course yep and it's
free so I think it's pretty cool that's
pretty awesome it's worth mentioning
like it is built by Google like it's a
google program in conjunction with
Udacity it does talk about tensorflow as
well which we talked about previously as
well exactly but it says it's in an
intermediate to advanced level course
but it sounds like it could be pretty
cool yeah I think that you will never
you will definitely need some basis on
machine learning but at the end of this
course you should be able to use sense
of flow like a pro basically so
I think it's if you have the time to
goes for the course I get definitely
good yeah that sounds like it'd be
really cool awesome great so let's go
talk with our colleague 10th on 10 let's
do it so we're joined today by one of
our most illustrious coworkers Jen
tongue Jen how are you doing today doing
great how are you very very well thank
you so much for joining us today horse
so we wanted to talk to you about
Internet of Things and that sort of fun
stuff but why don't you let us know who
you are what you do your background etc
so people have an idea who you are sure
thing so hi everybody I'm Jen I'm a
developer advocate at Google and I focus
on Google cloud platform that means in a
nutshell that I help people cause
trouble with code or build cool stuff
and then you know join them in the
satisfaction of accomplishing something
great and along the way I help people
understand why cloud technologies are
awesome and can make their life easier
cool cool do you focus on any particular
products and stuff I mean obviously want
to talk about it in a things but I'm
just kind of curious yep so kind of the
area I focus on is parts of the cloud to
either make like IOT prototyping really
easy which is I guess what we'll be
talking a little bit more about today
but also the other side of the equation
is Internet of Things devices are really
good at generating a whole bunch of data
so i spent a lot of time focusing on the
big data side of that things like
bigquery and pub/sub and big table nice
yes go so I'm going to be curious about
the intent of things I've heard many
definitions of it what is yours the
owner of the things the way I define it
is any device that didn't used to be
associated with internet connection so
something smaller than a laptop smaller
than a smartphone usually that connects
to the internet and then allows you to
access it in ways that you you know you
did not previously expect so using the
same set of protocols and other
languages that we use to do anything
else on the Internet so what would be
some examples of that so in my favorite
examples is something that people don't
really usually associate with the
Internet of Things is the rise of like
uber and lyft and the other
um internet-connected rideshare services
and this is because it took something
that didn't used to be connected to the
internet which was essentially like cars
ride share taxi cabs and then connected
in the internet using people's
smartphones which was really cool and
then suddenly like it became a lot
easier to use and it spawned a whole new
marketplace which was you know kind of
an amazing thing yeah I never thought
about over or live being intentional
things but tony make sense the internet
of cars yeah so man ok interesting you
could all made you ok so would you
classify like Airbnb is it in tentative
things Airbnb I don't know as much
because there's not really a lot like
there's no specific Hardware involved
true Airbnb more to me seems like a hub
of payment gateways that's here that's
more ok fair enough which is pretty cool
too it [ __ ] the houses don't move as
much they don't need that I mean the
moment they add like location specific
temperature predictions and stuff like
that then they would probably put them
over the edge would be pretty cool yeah
a little by the nation's at each house
yeah looks like nest really yeah yeah
actually one I thought about Internet of
Things one of the first things that came
to mind was a toothbrush like can you
talk a little bit more about that like
he's also internal things when you start
connecting random stuff like toothbrush
or yeah like Ness like thermostats is
also that internet of things yeah we're
seeing that happen all over the place
now people things that I used to just be
standalone and like had their own you
know potentially their own API is they
might have had a way to digitally
interface with them over Bluetooth or
something but suddenly they're starting
to come into existence with web servers
or other proprietary ways of pushing
data to the cloud like toothbrushes
refrigerators washing machines and it's
suddenly making them a lot more
functional and then magically you can
use them from any internet-connected
device which is cool nice that sounds
good and soon you know my fridge can
tell me about all the stuff I really
should have thrown out but haven't yet
already yeah I'm still waiting for the
day when the fridge will be able to send
a notification to my phone saying is
like hey you're running out of Mallik
stuff like that I want my fridge to send
a note of Amazon saying hey just sent
him some milk automatically cuz he's
already run out and I don't have to do
anything that's really
like it yeah nice so there was a little
bit about how did you get involved with
the Internet of Things ah so I'm gonna
have to go further back on that my
education university was focused on both
electrical and computer engineering so
at the beginning of my career I spent
time working on things like robotics in
fact I had a little little run doing
robotics at NASA and actually hated it
back then it was uh it was really hard
because we didn't have all the cool
debugging and all the neat stuff that
like the internet was was bringing to
other kinds of development so I took a
break and focused on web development for
most of my career because debuggers are
awesome and then you know I kind of
pushed it aside until one day someone's
like hey there's this new Arduino thing
Electronics is easy now and I didn't
believe it at first but you know I
picked up an arduino starter kit and I
was hooked and then it was just a matter
of time before Wi-Fi shields and other
things that allowed those easy to use
electronics to start getting connected
to the Internet appeared on the market
and then you know suddenly it was fun
and easy to build stuff that used to be
kind of a pain to build nice I'm a
little bit curious about the rubber part
uh what kind of Roberts were you
building can you share that cuz it was
NASA so i'm not sure if you could say oh
they're all they're all public projects
who that all been cancelled since but
one of the ones i spent the most time on
was called the crew return vehicle which
was the escape pod for the space station
which has since been cancelled but the
idea behind it was it was a mostly
automated return system so you wouldn't
have to have as much training for the
pilots on the space station and i worked
on a physical robot testbed for the
software that did things like automated
docking and release that's awesome very
cool but you're a cloud developer
advocate so how do they like how does a
cloud get in touch with the internet of
things are they the same thing how are
they related so it's kind of the
internet part of the Internet of Things
because all the electronics and like the
embedded operating systems and all that
stuff makes a thing that could be very
intelligent but once you attach it to
the internet a cloud is a logical way to
add internet capabilities
so are there any particular challenges
on the cloud side like I'm guessing if
you have lots of any of the things you
need deal with like scale or you talk a
little bit about big data and tell us a
little bit more about how that works yes
there's a couple to come to mind the
first one is Internet of Things devices
tend not to be the most intelligent
systems because you're going to want to
use lower power things that are less
smart so they tend to generate a lot of
data which is cool because you can do
cool things with lots of data like
machine learning and all that stuff but
it is a different kind of data than what
we're used to from like web development
so it stresses a lot of our traditional
database and like REST API systems that
we built up the power web apps so we
have to kind of take a little bit of a
different approach to handling that much
throughput of data which is where things
like pub/sub and big table really shine
another aspect of it is Internet of
Things is also about low power systems
and transport layer security is usually
a big challenge and actually is
responsible for a lot of the complexity
in sending data and a secure way to the
Internet so that's one that usually
spend a lot of a lot of watts and a lot
of effort overcoming they have some
advice about security on the internet of
things because that's one of the things
that every single time i read about
internet of things on the newspaper is
because someone hacked like i've read
about someone hacking a toothbrush and
they were able to access your passwords
or something like that like what kind of
techniques you should implement to avoid
that those things what kind of
techniques a lot of this goes back to
kinda the same techniques were used to
doing from other kinds of development
the first one that i would always
recommend is don't reinvent security
yourself we have protocols like
transport layer security that we are you
know we're pretty confident work really
well use those don't try that your own
encryption scheme to save a few bits of
overhead the other aspect is you know
hard off is it is a good way to make
sure that things like microphones and
things can can stay off when you're not
actually using them for your device this
take advantage of physical off I'm
plugin that did exactly the most secure
computer is when there's no plug to the
internet or power yeah that's not my
vintage that
works well that sounds really
interesting so if people want to get
involved with the Internet of Things or
there so they interested in that sort of
platform where should they go what
should they do so most of the people I
talked to her just kind of getting into
the dinner and out of things excitement
have web development background yep so
this is where I kind of steer them in a
specific direction is there's this
really cool growing community of people
building node box and know about is
mostly focused on the electronic side
and using javascript control robots and
electronics but because you're using
javascript all the neat web stuff that
we've done that work well in JavaScript
and well a node also work on these
robots which is really cool because you
can fall back on all the tricks and
techniques and design patterns that you
learn from building JavaScript and web
applications except you can use them on
electronic so that like having to learn
a whole new language and a whole bunch
of new frameworks so what does that sort
of development process look like so if
I'm writing Java scripts and I have I
guess some sort of physical thing like
how do i connect to it what does that
look like what sort of thing would I
have like I don't know I don't know
anything about this stuff really so
usually when I steer people to if they
just want to get started is a first like
use whatever you have available if you
have something available and what a lot
of people turns out already have is a
Raspberry Pi in that Arduino Uno that
they picked up from a Kickstarter or
they got at a conference and they're on
some shelf somewhere gathering dust so I
to do that the first recipe I give
people is they install nodejs on a
Raspberry Pi and I'm use a USB cable to
plug it into their arduino uno and use a
protocol called for mana which comes
with the Arduino SDK to communicate with
the Arduino and then do with all their
electronics work on the Arduino because
it is a wonderfully robust and durable
board and is very tolerant of mistakes
that would burn out other deaf boards
that's good that's one of the things
that I actually learned quite quick what
was that depending on how you plug stuff
you might burn it down which yeah it's
kind of sad if you only have one of them
actually for me one of the biggest
problems it was not the programming part
of it when I got started was for
instance if you want to have a let that
little LED then
blinks you actually have to add some
resistors in the middle and I didn't
know how to do that like what is your
advice what how do I learn these things
so my advice is not to fear things going
wrong and to copy things where possible
to get started because it's always easy
just like a software project it's always
easier to start from something that's
already working so coincidentally like
my favorite JavaScript library Johnny 5
which is used by a lot of node BOTS has
a wonderful documentation that also is
really good kind of like primer to
electronics so whether you get it from
the Johnny Five Docs or like the Arduino
Uno starter study of the starter pack
and the instruction manual they're all
those things have pictures of like the
circuits you should build and then an
explanation of why they should work that
way and usually code that goes along
with it to get it working so at the very
beginning I wouldn't spend a lot of time
trying to get a deep understanding of
why just find pictures copy them get
them working and then explore and expect
things to burn up every once in a while
and you know get used to it and then
then then you understand will grow over
time and your bag of tricks will will
improve and things will won't catch on
fire less often hopefully yes now do you
have a favorite like getting started
project I hear like blinking light tends
to be the hello world of Internet of
Things is that that kind of the truth
yep so along with that recipe I
described with the Raspberry Pi with
Johnny 5 and 4 matta and nodejs and
their Arduino Uno the first project I
usually recommend people is a an
Internet button that turns on an LED so
you you wire up a button and when you
press the button you send a signal out
to the cloud I usually steer people
towards firebase for the first project
you flip something in firebase and then
you have a firebase client on the same
or another you know set of this another
Raspberry Pi then um receives that
signal and then turns on an LED when the
button is down do you want to talk a
little bit about what firebases and
maybe how it fits in with IOT we haven't
really talked about firebase too much on
this podcast ah got it so firebase is
was an independent company that got
acquired by google in late 2014 and it
is a way to is kind of like generally a
bad
goodies that you can use to build apps
like web apps and mobile apps and it
works really great with javascript and
nodejs which means it also plays
exceptionally well with no dots and the
data model behind firebase one of the
components of firebase being a real-time
database is you have a big bowl of JSON
in the sky in the cloud and all of your
apps and devices can write to any
location and they can also listen to a
location and whenever one of those
locations changes or has a new child
added or something gets moved the
firebase client will automatically call
a callback function that you specify in
your code and what this does is it makes
like all the multi threading and
synchronization stuff it kind of handles
that for you so it makes building
internet things devices like so much
easier than like you know having pulling
loops and stuff like that so it sounds
like firebase is probably one of your
very much recommended starting places of
all right I've got all these devices out
there and I need to synchronize data
between them either coming in or going
out I can just plug it all into firebase
and then hopefully magic happens and
everything's okay yeah firebase excels
at prototyping for like web and mobile
apps on and for the same same strengths
the same reasons it also excels at
prototyping IOT devices so it is
wonderfully awesome especially for
building one of something which is
usually the first step on an IOT project
yeah do add a little bit on firebase I
we used it for cloud spin and one of the
good things about it is that you build
whatever you want to build on firebase
and then at some point you're like oh
wait we need a visualizer to understand
what the system is doing and that's
super simple to do because all the data
is already on the cloud so you don't
need to export anything extra you can
just build and you really tiny web page
that shows whatever you're interested on
so yeah people have not tried on I think
it's a great place to start yeah and up
to 100 concurrent users as part of our
like our developer plan which is free
free forever which is awesome nice
that's very cool very very cool so I
have to ask would have been like your
favorite IOT projects maybe something
weird and wacky something somebody's
done that seems a bit interesting and
cool so a lot of people are interested
in IOT for like you know saving money
establishing new
this is and that kind of stuff but my
favorite projects can go back to the
crazy like LED powered RC scene that's
really really popular especially here
around San Francisco and because of the
declining cost of light-emitting diodes
blinky lights and centers and all that
stuff people are building these really
cool giant and installation or even
small desktop sets of like interactive
art work that our internet connected and
allow you to interact with the artwork
and multiple people around you in really
cool ways nice so like setting up
sensors where like people walk through
or is touch or play and then it sort of
responds in some interesting in
wonderful ways yeah at a popular thing
I'm starting to see a lot is all of us
are walking around with little internet
computers or smartphones and that's a
really really great way to have people
interact with with some other already
internet-connected device very cool very
very cool so you also mentioned I just
want to make sure it's very clear for
listeners as well you mentioned a whole
bunch of different hardware so like
Arduino and a couple of other things is
that your favorite how where to use or
do you have other favorite things that
you like to use so usually what i
recommend the people's use what you
already have anything that's so if you
have anything that's like a Raspberry Pi
which is like a board that runs in just
a full computer that runs an operating
system you can probably run node and
Johnny 5 on it which is awesome like you
can go to the web page and there's a
huge list of board so if you have like
an Edison or one of the other boards
like it'll still work on there so I
usually encourage people to use what you
already have but the reason like given
like no other assumptions i sear people
towards the the pie and the uno as a
pair is because they are big bonus there
everywhere people have lots of them the
documentation a community around both of
them is very very rich and active and in
case you do accidentally burn one of
them up they're pretty low cost that
sounds good actually we talked a little
bit about low cost is there where we
there been a certain shift over the
certain number years in like that's
what's made this so popular because of
the the shift of cost coming down has
that been like I'm guessing a fairly
large factor in sort of a IOT space yeah
like if you look back even a few years
ago it was much more expensive to to get
a device onto the internet mostly
because of like the complexity in the
software like for example in your
writing code
arduino if you're just coding on the
Arduino you don't have an operating
system usually so you you lack things
like virtual memory and importantly an
Internet stack and an interrupt
controller and then the rise of these
tiny tiny tiny full-fledged computers
suddenly made it much easier to get
things connected to the Internet and
around the same time the hardware that
allows you to connect to Wi-Fi like our
existing Internet infrastructure also
came down at the same time so there's
kind of a convergence of those things
over the last few years that have
suddenly made this like so much easier
and so much more fun to hack on could
you give a little bit of what you think
might happen in the future like you do
you think that is gonna keep on going
I'm gonna have more and more little
computers everywhere what is your vision
of the future always the little things
that's a big question is if you get it
wrong then we're gonna come off to you I
don't know yeah it is it's so scary so
the vision is is we're just going to get
better and better at building these
electronics we're also going to get
better and better at coming up with the
bag of tricks for making these things
work so on the electronic side I expect
things to get cheaper like 11 board that
came out recently Kim almost out of
nowhere as called the esp8266 which is
this tiny little Wi-Fi chip but that's
like two dollars and I starting to take
our around a lot with it now and it's
like the cheapest way I seem to get
devices onto Wi-Fi and I know a lot of
people are researching like these like
Bluetooth mesh networks and stuff but
like those protocols aren't ready yet so
the like everything I work on now I
usually use Wi-Fi because it's already
there and seeing suddenly like it come
hit a huge drop in cost imply it shows
me that like that's not going to be a
big blocker and we're going to have lots
of low-cost electronics and then on the
the flip side of that is kind of our
software and design patterns is we're
still leaning a lot on the the bag of
tricks that we developed for solving web
web problems you know loading web pages
and all that kind of stuff but as is the
way we you know build web apps changes
and mobile apps we're starting to come
up with new techniques for the way we
use caches and the way we handle bursts
of messages and that kind of stuff which
is going to make it easier and easier to
use existing services ap eyes and open
source projects to solve your IOT
problems ok
nice all right well thank you very much
for joining us jen is there anything at
all that we haven't talked about you
want to talk about if we missed anything
oh I guess though the one thing that I
would definitely put out there is
sometimes people kind of go down a
rabbit hole on how like they would build
a million of something or a thousand of
something before they even get there
first you know the first jumper cable
into their into their bread board I
would encourage people to not focus too
much on the manufacturing side at least
not at the very beginning spend time
like if you have an idea and you want to
build something build one of something
don't worry about the manufacturing
later and then use that one prototype
you've built to validate your idea and
get user feedback much the same way we
build you know mock-ups and scaffolding
and web applications nice well thank you
so much for all the hand side that was
very interesting conversation definitely
yeah you're very welcome most a lot of
fun thanks for having me on kiss well
thanks so much to Jen for joining us
today a fascinating conversation i love
that hardware stuff mainly because I
just don't understand a lot of it so any
peek behind the magic curtain that I can
find it makes me pretty happy I know
that I've been playing a little bit
breathe an Arduino and it's awesome you
can really do so many cool things yeah
in a quite easy way so yeah very excited
about seeing more of these things of
related to the club definitely
definitely so moving on to our question
of the week this is an interesting one
to a little bit less technical but I
think just as important it's a question
around so is there any Google cloud
platform certification or training like
if you need to be able to say yes I
definitely know this thing how do you
get that piece of paper that says that
you definitely do so the answer is of
course yes there's actually a web page
with all the trainings that we support
and that link is actually cloud of Allah
come / training quite obviously and you
will find there a bunch of different
classes some of the classes like CP 100
cp200 CB 300 those are like the main
classes where you're going to learn
about general topics of the cloud you're
starting from what
the cloud and why and how they store my
data how do connect between different
instances that kind of stuff two things
are way more evolved like you will be
able to see something like very specific
about well how do I package my
containers my docker containers to be
deployed into a container engine and
stuff like that there's so you will find
a bunch of different trainings and also
certifications I'm actually looking
through and I didn't honestly realize
that we had this many training programs
in here from like like darker packaging
and through till like cloud storage
through the App Engine equal yeah i can
find basically everything you you might
be interested in now this is actually
really really interesting ok and a
variety of locations to somewhere online
some are actually physically in
particular places that's actually
regulated not know that yeah it is is a
very interesting resource because you
you will have access to a lot of
different material and then at the end
you pretty much forcing yourself to
study to go through those certifications
yep and once you get them they kinda
showing that yeah i like you know what
you're doing yeah now it's really
interesting i'm i was reading through
the FAQ in it and it's worth is worth
noting that you don't necessarily have
to take the training course to pass the
exams if you feel like you have enough
knowledge like you worked with it enough
we're never going to stop you we
recommended of course but nothing
nothing to necessarily stop you so if
you've been working with a particular
product for a while and you want to have
that certification definitely something
you can go for yeah i think it's
definitely worth it and yeah once you
have the certification right now it
doesn't it doesn't expire uh basically
because it's quite new but it's these
kind of things that basically you want
to do regularly because our products
keep on evolving so saying that you are
an expert on a technology but you got
that certification two years ago well i
mean it's still valid of course but it's
always good to try to refresh those
those certifications if that's something
that can help your career really know
that sounds pretty reasonable on top of
that one research that i use very often
is actually not trained but the
solutions page oh yeah yeah so glad the
volcom / solutions and here they're our
solutions engineers share use cases and
white papers about specifically how to
do some some technical thing oh yeah
there's this some some of the solutions
are like group by topic so you can have
like internal things for instance that
one of them but you're also gonna gaming
etc but at the same time you're gonna
see also something some stuff that is
really specific like white paper on how
to deploy correctly MongoDB and google
cloud platform stuff like that not a lot
of different parameters so our solutions
engineers but what they do is they will
write they will basically explain what
is the good value for every single
parameter what is the design decision
behind those and so on so it's really
really interesting to go through some of
those like papers so if you're looking
to do like some sort of i don't know
maybe a gaming analytics platform or
something like that and you think
yourself how would i go about doing that
going through the solutions like that
are already listed in there can probably
give you a leg up to be like okay this
is this is our recommended way of doing
it yeah definitely i think it's it's
really good we're social engineers so i
get to work with some of them from time
to time they're amazing they're really
really know what they're doing yeah and
they're really good writers so
definitely go have a look wonderful
alright francisc should we let people
know where we're going to be for the
next few weeks well by the time this
episode will be out I will rather be in
Paris for the Deaf fest now so that's on
febri febri fifth we have a deaf espares
there's gonna be lots of fun i'm gonna
be talking about gr pc and communities
and everything we can go and i might try
to do the talking French oh good luck
it's always fun people make fun of my
accent upon yes
I some Canadian somehow I know what
about you still the same stuff so i'll
be on vacation for a couple of weeks but
when i get back i have the launch
hackathon which is always fun i always
loved doing hackathons wait and then on
top of that yep Game Developers
Conference still got lots of plans
happening with that will definitely have
a booth space and events going on we're
doing a developer day we can talk
developers and do a bunch of talks so
that's sort of stuff too so if you're
interested in gaming and Google cloud
platform definitely come and say hello
we'd love to speak to you and then
obviously we'll both be gcb next yeah
we'll be there doing all sorts of
interesting stuff or maybe something
podcast e we'll see we'll see what
happens if you feel good is it cred or
even we're not really sure what's gonna
happen yeah it's gonna be something
something will be happening yeah I will
say and then after that i will be at
strata right running some stuff down
there as well too great uh so before we
say goodbye I think it's a great moment
to refresh how to get in contact with us
yes and we definitely want the
interaction and we definitely want the
comments and support so please
definitely send things through okay so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with every single
media and you say okay let's do it let's
do I gay so first of all is our webpage
at gcp podcast calm and on email hello
at JCP podcast calm there we have a
twitter handle gcd podcast we have
reddit subreddit subreddit which is /
are gcp podcast and finally we have
google buzz at google com for / + gcp
podcast nice so yeah as always if you
have any questions we always looking for
questions of the week or cool things if
you've got something that's particularly
exciting love to see it if you wanna
have a son topic covered or you're doing
something amazing with the Google cloud
platform and you wanna tell us about it
I'm on the podcast definitely pockets
we're always happy to interview new
people wonderful well thank you so much
for joining me yet again France esque
thank you Mark and see you next week
you